to me I would see these guys that were  you know 65 70 years old that all they  had basically was that they worked out  they sprayed tanned and got hair plugs  they had their little dogs and they  partied on the weekends and probably  chased the same sexual escapades that  they were chasing 40 years ago  yeah and it's not it's not a full life  if you don't give people the same  opportunity to be in a relationship what  will you leave them with you will leave  them with their carnal desires I would  say it's got to be the case that the  hope so to speak of the more enlightened  conservative types who were willing to  open the door to gay marriage was that  by bringing those relationships inside  the traditional fold that things would  normalize yeah and that there would be a  promotion of something like stable  mature responsible long-term monogamy  well I think maybe I'm trying to prove  that